England are through now to the
quarterfinal against France you were in
England so many years at Manchester
United you saw England team struggling
tournaments why do you think this
England team seems to be doing so well
I think I think probably they believe
each other and then they trust each
other it is more
they have a great communication each
other as a as a team player so that's a
different from a probably previous
England generation this is a new
generation so they have a different mind
and not different mentality so and then
probably Southgate to really manage to
wear as a team so yeah that's why
they've been brilliant in the Euro and
then last world where as well who
impresses you the most in that England
side oh yeah it's difficult but yeah
actually if I choose one in the province
of Bellingham
and plus the other was rashford you know
so these two players is great you know
through the their group stage which
thing England can challenge to win this
world cup you obviously think Brazil are
favorites you'll want South Korea to go
through as well but how far do you think
England can go I think they they have a
big chance you know if they beat the
France then then they went to sanfana so
it'll become a big chance for them to
win the the World Cup but as you
mentioned it's not easy and then England
never had had won the last World because
it's 1966 so it's been a long time for
the English fans to lift their trophy
but yeah they have a big chance but as
as this is World Cup you need the lock
as well so hopefully they can I want to
see the how long how far they can go